this is another Fox News Alert we expect
we will find out one week from today
what the Justice Department Inspector
General has determined about the FBI
investigation into Hillary Clinton's
email scandal chief intelligence works
by catherine herridge with us tonight
she's got some breaking details good
evening Catherine well thank you Shannon
this is the firmest state yet from
inspector general Michael Horowitz with
his report examining the FBI in Justice
Department's actions leading up to the
2016 election the original mandate
focused on the Clinton email case but
the title of the congressional hearing
suggests the scope may be broader this
comes as the push and pull over another
set of secret government records
intensifies just after midnight at
senior Justice Department official told
reporters that DOJ would offer
congressional leadership known as the
gang of eight another briefing and
access to FBI confidential source
records Monday or Tuesday next week
requested by House Intelligence
Committee Chairman Devin Nunez
working alongside Oversight Committee
Chairman trey Gowdy the records are now
subject to a congressional subpoena they
are expected to shed more light on
allegations an FBI confidential source
contacted Trump campaign aides in the
early stages of the Russia case multiple
congressional sources told Fox the
documents were promised for this morning
but the Justice Department backed out
true House Speaker Paul Ryan what we are
asking for and what we require and we
expect is the corroborating documents
that backup that oral briefing and last
night they could have brought it to us
today and they chose to do it next week
that doesn't help the Justice Department
official also acknowledged the records
were not available to lawmakers at the
last session two weeks ago adding quote
the Department FBI are prepared to brief
members on certain questions
specifically raised by the speaker and
other members the Department will also
provide the documents that were
available for review but not inspected
by the members along with some
additional material at his weekly news
conference the speaker said he fully
supports his congressional investigators
and expressed frustration it shouldn't
take a speaker of the house to have to
get involved every one of these times to
get the Department of Justice or any
department in the executive branch to
comply with congressional oversight
requests Democrats dismissed the
president's spy allegations and defend
special counsel Robert molar there's no
evidence of a spy collusion let's wait
to find out what Muller finds out and
everyone should leave him alone and let
him get to the bottom and hear what he
has to say the house intelligence
committees ranking Democrat said the
Justice Department offer was fraught
with risk studying the ongoing Russia
case quote the further disclosure of
investigative materials is inexplicable
the DOJ is now reinforcing a precedent
it will have to live with whether the
Congress is in Republican or Democratic
hands
former Justice Department officials said
the struggle comes down to powerful
competing interests robust congressional
oversight versus the department's need
to protect ongoing investigations
Shannon Catherine Herridge thank you
very much